خلال زلزال هنشيل الذي ضرب اليابان عام
1995 قتل نحو 6,000 شخص الا مبنى واحد في
المدينه لم يتاثر بالزلزال العنيف المبنى
تملكه شركه انشاءات هندسيه يابانيه جعلت
اساساته من المطاط الخاص في نسخه تجريبيه
وقتها لتقنيه بناء تسمى تقنيه عزل الالقاب
اليوم بحسب نيويورك تايمز تستخدم هذه
التقنيه في نحو 9000 مبنى في اليابان
بينما زودت الاف المباني الاخرى باجهزه
امتصاص الصدمات فيما يقول خبراء ان عدم
اعتماد هذه التقنيات ضيعه فرصه حمايه
الارواح وتوفير مليارات الدولارات من
تكاليف اعاده الاعمار على كل حال هذا ما
يتضح في اعلام السلطات التركيه انها تخطط
لهدم اكثر من 50 الف مبنى تضرر بفعل
الزلزال الاخير كونها لا يمكن ترميمها او
حتى اصلاح
طيب دكتور ارخبيل اليابان مثلا يقع على
حزام النار اكثر منطقه نشطه زلزاليا حول
العالم رغم ذلك عند وقوع اقوى الزلازل
نشاهد المباني الشاهقه تتمايل واكثر مرونه
وصمودا في وجه الزلزال هذه الصف في ذلك ان
اليابان تصمم مبانيها على زلزال كانتو
الذي حصل عام 1923 وهم يستخدمون البنايات
المرنه ويستخدمون مبدا العزل الزلزالي
للاساسات فعندما يكون العزل الزلزالي
للاساسات ممكن تخفيف مقدار الطاقه الناتجه
من الزلزال الى المبنى بمقدار 80% فهذا
عامل مهم من تخفيف التعجيل الارضي القادم
الى المبنى ومن ثم تصميم المباني بحداتها
لكي تكون مرنه دكتور طالما اشرت على ذكر
تصميم المباني اليوم في بيوت خصوصا خلال
العقد الماضي يتم تصميمها تكون فيها غرفه
مضاده للحروب يعني مثلا جدران حصينه منيعه
وباب مضاد للرصاص وكل ما الى ذلك هل يمكن
تصميم منزل مضاد للزلازل 100% او غرفه
معينه يتم اللجوء اليها نعم طبعا تصمم
المباني بناء على المدونات الزلزاليه فبلا
شك يمكن تصميم المباني القصيره الارتفاع
او المتوسطه او العاليه بناء على
المتطلبات الزلزاليه لكل مبنى ولكل نوع
معين بحسب وجودي بحسب شده الهزات الارضيه
في تلك المنطقه بناء على مقدار التعجيل
الارضي في تلك المناطق يتم تصميم هذه
المباني التي تفضلت بها طبعا عندما اتحدث
دكتوره عن اهميه العوازل زلزاليه يعني
بناء سطح او قاعده
لامتصاص صدمات الزلزال في كل مبنى هل
منطقتنا هل الدول كل الدول العالم لها
القدرات لبنائها كذا مباني هذا الموضوع
طبعا يصمم في المباني الزلزاليه الواقعه
على الزلزال شديد التاثر وعاده في في
اليابان وفي كاليفورنيا في غرب امريكا وفي
غرب كندا لان قوه الزلازل تكون عاليه وهذه
كذلك مكلفه تقريبا هي 20% من من تكلفه
المبنى ولكنها عمليه بسيطه هي عباره عن
اجزاء يا اما من المطاط او الحديد والقصاص
يبلغ ارتفاعها بين 30 الى 50 سم
وتؤدي الى امتصاص الطاقه وبالتالي تخفيف
شده الهزل الارضيه الواقعه على المبنى